what we found
um again working with the theorists of
course who run these Supernova models
is that so actually let me let me before
I get into this these two stars had huge
amounts of carbon relative to iron so we
usually use iron as a reference element
for what we call the metallicity so the
overall metal content the overall amount
of heavy elements in it so that's why
it's called iron deficiency that's right
so these stars are incredibly iron
deficient which means there must be of
the second generation because
there was and interestingly enough
there was this discrepancy
a normal Supernova until then we thought
would get us so much iron
you know you would distribute that in
the gas cloud and then you would form
this little star that we're observing
but the iron abundance that we measured
was actually much lower than that and I
already mentioned you can't take things
away that must mean these early massive
pop three we call them population three
the first Stars
they must have exploded in a different
way than we previously thought they
can't output as much iron because
they just can't otherwise it wouldn't
match our observations got it and so
that's when we started to work with uh
several Theory groups
on on supernova yields so what comes out
of from the explosion of the Supernova
that's called Supernova yields and so
this one was not yielding much iron well
we needed to concoct a theoretical
Supernova that made less
and it's actually surprisingly difficult
because you can always add more in the
universe right but you can't take stuff
away so Japanese colleagues kind of came
up with the idea of a fainter Supernova
that just doesn't have a much is enough
oomph you know when it explodes so
somehow there's there's less iron coming
out but at the same time then these
Stars showed huge over bonuses of carbon
you know a thousand times more carbon
so how do you now get a thousand times
more carbon out of these poor first
supernovia that was the theoretical
Challenge and because we didn't have
just one star but two
um that really spurred the field to
think about what was the nature of the
first Stars how did they explode what
what are the implications because if
they are not as as luminous and bright
and energetic that has consequences for
for these early proto-galaxies in in
which you know they must have been
located in terms of you know blowing the
gas out let's say interrupting the
system so much higher chance for the the
earlier system to stay intact for longer
right so there's a whole tale of
consequences and this is what I mean
with we need to find the story because
you do you one thing and it's like The
Dominoes the consequences everywhere and
then you have a different Universe right
so what could possibly be a good
explanation for something that that
yields a lot of carbon and doesn't yield
a lot of iron
well it's not so much an explanation
more like finding a mechanism for what
happens in supernovae and the the
official term what what was sort of as I
said cooked up in order to to explain
the observations and we have by the way
found a whole bunch more of these tasks
so that holds and it's called a fallback
mechanism so actually in in the uh
Supernova during the Supernova explosion
a massive um black hole emerges and so
some of the material falls back onto the
black hole so here is a a vacuum cleaner
now plopped into the middle right like a
temporary one that just cleans up
somewhere else sort of right because if
you think of the we haven't talked about
this yet but um if you if you know what
a star looks like a master star looks
like on its on its in its interior
before it explodes
um you have hydrogen helium still on the
outskirts and then you have your layers
of heavier and heavy elements all the
way up to iron so you have an iron core
in the center
um
and because you can't get any energy out
of iron when you want to fuse to iron
atoms anymore right that's when the
Supernova explodes well occurs really
it's actually an implosion first and
then you have a bounce of of the the
sort of neutron star phase that that
that occurs in the process and then it's
so awesome gets disrupted yeah it's like
this giant you know basketball and then
it all goes up explosion first explosion
yeah and so in the process right if you
make your black hole basically big
enough it will suck away some of the
iron because that's the closest in the
in terms of the layers you you you you
hold on to it you don't let it escape
and carbon is much further out you let
it all go
and so so that explains why you can have
a big oomph and not much iron yield yes
yes so does this explain the he 1327
correct uh and others like it yes so
there's a there's uh it's very well
established now that the lower the iron
abundance of the stars are the higher
the carbon sort of gets and carbon is is
such an interesting element in that
regard
if if we come back to the formation of
the first Lomas does right so we had the
the hotter gas just hydrogen helium that
made the first stars there were 100
solar masses or so because it could the
gas couldn't cool enough so they were
big and puffy
carbon then coming from the first Stars
probably led to enough Cooling in these
gas clouds that enabled the formation of
the first lawmesters
so think about what happened if there
wouldn't have been any carbon or the
properties of the carbon atom would be
different it would not have cooled the
gas in such significant ways perhaps
there wouldn't be any low masters
we wouldn't be here today right and
we're carbon based and so I think carbon
is really the most important element in
the universe for for a variety of
reasons because it is just enabled this
whole Evolution that that we're now
observing and literally seeing in the
sky
and it's really fascinating so combined
with the fact that you have the iron
deficient so all of that is probably
important to creating
humans yeah yeah we need all the
elements but if you don't have stars you
know like the sun small stars that can
actually host planets that have long
lifetimes you need long long lifetimes
if you want to have a stable planet
and and develop humans so carbon is kind
of important in many ways yes yes